[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous ces paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux alors on commence par une image
cette image que vous voyez vous affiche
à lille à l'écran c'est un dinosaure à
plumes qui vient du film jurassic world
mignonne ça y est enfin
il se décide à nous mettre des
dinosaures à plumes dans jurassic world
ça fait jamais que depuis 2015 qu'on
leur demande
mais ça y est c'est fait il va y avoir
des dinosaures à plumes
alors ça c'est une image en fait qui
nous vient d'un preview des cinq
premières minutes du film qui est en ce
moment diffusé juste avant le film fast
and furious au cinéma donc si vous allez
au cinéma pour voir fast and furious
vous verrez ces cinq premières images de
jurassic world dominion si vous êtes un
fan ultra hardcore de jurassic world
dominion fa de jurassic world vous irez
voir fast and furious grande pour ça
faut aimer la douleur mais voilà ça
c'est le l'image qui a été vraiment
diffusés à grande échelle donc je ne
pense pas que ça compte comme un spoiler
tout aveu pour être tout à fait honnête
mais enfin ils vont mettre des des
dinosaures à plumes dans leur jurassique
world dominion il faut voir que jurassic
web dominion c'est un film qui fait peur
c'est un film qui fait très peur parce
qu'il nous avait quand même sorti des
affiches promotionnelles de ce jus là où
vous voyez un magnifique moustiques ici
un très très beau très esthétique mais
alors avec seulement quatre pattes
voilà merci vincent régnier lô de
m'avoir signalé cette magnifique
anomalies donc gérer un sequel de
mignonnes ils nous sortent quand même
des choses un peu tiré un peu comment
dire chaud c'est un peu chaud du cul
voilà j'ai du mal à m'exprimer parce que
c'est mais mes sentiments sont
extrêmement mitigé à propos de jurassic
world dominion à propos de la saga
jurassic world en général je veux dire
je n'ai jamais caché mon je n'ai jamais
caché ma désapprobation de
notamment du numéro 2 fallen kingdom
mais bref la saga jurassic world c'est
donc une saga qu'on regarde avec un
préhension et cette saga qu'on regarde
avec un préhension continue de nous
faire peur en nous proposant des visuels
comme ce moustique à quatre pattes est
alors du coup ça rassure de voir des
dinosaures à plumes
alors à partir du moment je vais à
partir de maintenant je vais spoiler les
cinq minutes de preview donc si vous ne
voulez rien savoir du film je vous
conseille d'aller à ce thème code qui
s'affiche maintenant à l'écran voilà je
la fiche en gros pour que bien vous bien
voire mieux comme cela on va aller à ce
time code si vous ne voulez pas être
spoilé dans qu'est ce qu'on voit dans ce
preview et qui à mon avis fait un petit
peu peur
ça fait un petit peu peur à la fois
scientifiquement mais je rappelle qu
évidemment on va tout de suite me sortir
c'est pas un documentaire ça va pas être
scientifique oui il fait pas seulement
peur scientifiquement le jeu trouve le
preview de jurassic world dominion il
fait aussi peur au niveau de la
cohérence générale de la saga je trouve
et je vais m'expliquer dès maintenant
donc dans l'ordre qu'est ce qu'on voit
dans ce trailer et qui m'ont et qui m'a
inquiété
déjà on voit des sauropodes tremper dans
l'eau jusqu'à l'épaule je rappelle quand
même que dans jurassic park 1
il y à une scène où alan grant pleure en
voyant un sauropode ne pas marcher dans
l'eau la grande scène tire larmes quand
il dit il se déplace en troupeau on voit
le brachiosaure sortir de l'eau quoi est
normalement c'est censé vous tirer une
larme à brachiosaures qui sort de l'eau
parce que c'est c'est une énorme étape
dans l'histoire de la paléontologie
d'avoir fait sortir les sauropodes et
les dinosaures de manière générale de
l'eure marécages et ben je rase et
cointe dominion il voulait remet
directement là quasiment tout se passe
dans la flotte
voilà donc c'est un peu inquiétant et
comme je dise ça ça rompt avec la
cohérence de la saga la cohérence de la
saga qui justement avait fait sortir les
dinosaures de l'eau donc voilà on se
retrouve avec des dinosaures dans l'eau
ensuite la raison pour laquelle on a des
dinosaures à plumes c'est parce que ça
ne se passe pas à l'époque où se passe
le film l'histoire du film
sequans dominion ça se passe à l'époque
des dinosaures donc des millions
d'années en avant je crois même qu à un
moment le ça nous a fichu que ces 65
millions d'années il y à 65 millions
d'années ce qui est pareil c'est
maintenant c'est plus déjà l'extinction
des dinosaures non aviens on place à 66
millions d'années maintenant plus
tellement à 65 millions d'années
et de toute façon les animaux étaient
vivants enfin la vivent et leur
meilleure vie avant ça le dire donc ça
aurait été peut-être plus judicieux de
choisir une date plus plus autour des 70
millions d'années mais bref ça c'est un
point de détail
le truc qui vient après les sauropodes
donc qui baignent dans l'eau c'est un
ovi raptor qui bouche d eux
[Rires]
ovi raptor qu'ils bouffent des oeufs ça
ça m'a ça m'a énervé là franchement si
j'avais pu faire un trailer réaction
thème allez me filmer dans le cinéma là
si je te fais un trailer réaction vous
m'auriez vu fulminé pas ce que c'était
waouh voir à novi raptor manger des
oeufs alors ovi raptor il tient son nom
justement du fait qu'on pensait que
c'était un mangeur neuf parce qu'on
l'avait retrouvé accompagné deux de
dinosaures c'est à chapman andrews qui
avait découvert donc servi raptor avec
des oeufs dessus est rude chapman
andrews en avait conclu du coup que
enfin ils avaient découvert d ovi raptor
et des oeufs qui les accompagnaient et
il y en avait conclut donc que les
objets raptor appartenant à la famille
des théropodes et étant donc supposément
carnivores devait s'attaquer aux yeux de
proto ceratops puisqu'il se trouvait
aussi dans le coin beaucoup de proto
ceratops il s'est avéré qu'en finale ce
nom de vie raptor donc voleurs duff
était très très mal portée puisque en
réalité les eaux via s'il s'agissait des
oeufs de dovi raptor eux mêmes donc
c'est eux dovi raptor kovy raptor était
censé être en train de manger c'était en
fait c'est le à lui donc maintenant on a
plein de vie raptor qui ont été
découverts en train de couver et il ya
même pas si longtemps que ça j'en ai
parlé dans un palais aux news on a même
découvert à novi raptor en train de
b d e qui eux-mêmes contenait des
embryons de vie raptor donc si jamais il
y avait le moindre doute sur sur ce que
faisait ovi raptor de ces eux s'étaient
pas aller manger c'est certain c'était
bien cea lui ai donc ça on le sait quand
même depuis au moins les années 90 la
dernière fois qu'on a vu à novi raptor
gober des yeux ou à essayer de gober des
oeufs au cinéma c'était petits pieds
donc c'était un petit pied et là on
retrouve ça on retrouve ça dans jurassic
world dominion à novi raptor en train de
manger des oeufs et c'est ça fait mal
mais ça fait mal
pourquoi vous mettez des plumes à vos
dinosaures à hilla des jolies plumes à
levie raptor il a déplu mais pourquoi
vous mettez des plumes aux dinosaures si
c'est pour faire des conneries encore
plus grosse derrière ça par contre je me
le demande je me le demande mais ce
n'est pas le pire ce n'est pas le pire
puisque encore une fois on va me
répondre mais oui mais c'est pareil si
c'est pas un documentaire c'est un
divertissement
oui alors le divertissement va
parlons-en du divertissement parce que
la partie divertissement c'est quand on
se rend compte que cette grosse mâchoire
là elle appartient un giganotosaurus
giganotosaurus qu'on va voir se battre
avec notre tyrannosaurus rex préférait
alors déjà tous les gens tous les gens
là qui se sont foutu de moi parce que je
vais voir godzilla versus kong
déjà on se calme voilà un tout de suite
ça vous calme mais on est bien sûr du
niveau godzilla versus kong un niveau
rencontre improbable puisqu'il ya quand
même 20 millions d'années qui les sépare
bon alors on va complètement oublié le
fait que les deux ne se sont jamais
croisés puisque giganotosaurus vivaient
en amérique du sud est
tyrannosaurus rex vivaient en amérique
du nord et qu'ils sont séparés par à peu
près 20 millions d'années ça on va
laisser de côté
donc on laisse de côté l'aspect
scientifique on va juste prendre ce que
ça raconte voilà qu'est ce que ça nous
raconte cet affrontement bas ça nous
raconte que t-rex a rencontré à
giganotosaurus et il s'est fait poutre
et en trois minutes voire même deux et
ça ça doit vous rappeler des vieux
cauchemars
normalement si vous êtes un vieux fans
de la saga jurassic park ça doit vous
rappeler des cauchemars un t-rex qui se
fait poutre et en trois minutes par
whatever rose or no one care zaurus d'un
début d'un film qui s'annonce est pas
terrible
oui vous vous le reconnaissez jurassic
park iii voilà donc le giganotosaurus
rend la relève du spinosaurus du
jurassic park iii et nous poutre notre
t-rex que jurassic world e 1 avait
réussi à ré iconiser c'était ça moi que
j'avais aimé dans jurassic war 2 1
jurassic war 2 1 avec tout le mal que
j'ai pu en dire c'est un film que je
considère comme un petit péché mignon
voilà c'est mon petit péché coupable
c'est mon petit plaisir coupable voilà
je laime bien parce que à la fin ils
reiko knees le tyrannosaure voilà la fin
ils arrivent ils défoncent ce squelette
de spinosaurus se venge de jurassic park
iii et hop ils défoncent un dinosaure
qui est plus gros plus forts plus
méchante lui et boum
voilà la sas est l'icônisation ben voilà
ce jour un cycle de trois jours a sequel
dominion au même titre que je racing
park iii est bien parti d'après ce
preview pour nous d zigoni zay notre
tyrannosaure voilà en tout cas c'est ce
qui va se passer dans les cinq premières
minutes dans les cinq premières minutes
votre t-rex préféré va se faire [ __ ]
et par un no man caire aux russes et
puis tant pis pour les fans du
giganotosaurus je veux dire si c'est
d'un banal d'être d'être fan du plus
gros carnivores veut dire bref c'est pas
plus banal que des fans du tyrannosaure
mais voilà le tyrannosaure c'est une
icône de la saga jurassic en général pas
seulement de jurassic park de jurassic
world c'est une icône de la saga
jurassic et il se fait dès mon trac dans
les cinq premières minutes et et voilà
ce que ça raconte et ça c'est pas joyeux
ben je trouve je trouve pas ça terrible
enfin bref donc voilà c'est pas
seulement pour ça que je disais c'est
pas seulement scientifiquement ces mêmes
cinématographiquement je ne trouve pas
que ça s'annonce terrible je trouve pas
que ça s'annonce terrible mais bref
et puis bon il ya le retour du casting
alors le casting on va en parler parce
que j'ai vu des vues d
des rumeurs de casting circuler où on
allait avoir le retour aussi du cast du
cast de jurassic park the lost world et
de jurassic park iii et si on a des
retours de ceux de ces gens là alors
c'est bien pour les fans youpi on revoit
les mêmes personnages pour ceux qui
avaient aimé le couple kirby dans
jurassic park iii où on va les revoir
mais je veux dire si ça s'avère vrai
comme rumeur est ce que si ça s'avère
vrai que ces gens là reviennent mais ça
veut dire que du coup on oublie le fait
que dans jurassic world 2 1
on était censé considérer que isla sorna
n'existait pas d'ailleurs la non
existence de isla sort n'a donc la
deuxième île avec des dinosaures la non
existence de l'islam en a est une
condition absolument primordiale pour
que fallen king dôme jurassique worlds 2
fonctionne ce n'est pas lille où ils
veulent amener les dinosaures
ce n'est pas isla sorna c'est une autre
île une nouvelle île donc je ne
comprends pas je ne comprends pas où ils
veulent en venir avec ses retours de
caste face et retour de casting des
anciens films mais ça fait peur je sais
pas après faut voir si c'est vrai ou pas
bref fin des spoilers vous pouvez
revenir
vous pouvez jump et jusque là c'est tout
ce que j'avais à dire sur jurassique
world dominion on va bien voir on verra
ça sert à rien de critiquer le film tant
qu'on l'a prévu mais évidemment je ne
pouvais pas ne pas traiter ça dans un
palais aux news je veux dire c'est pas
possible
voilà fallait bien que je le traite ici
c'est la news du mois quoi la sortie de
ces images de ces preview on passe
maintenant à l'actualité scientifique la
vraie la grosse science celle qu'on aime
avec un article paru dans nature's
communication donc une petite succursale
de la grande revue de la prestigieuse
revue nature's un nouveau fossile de
dinosaure de dinosaures chinois cette
fois c'est un petit oiseau et nocturne
it alors le titre est assez marrant
parce que j'ai eu des commentaires sur
ce titre
c'est un oiseau du crétacé avec un crâne
de dinosaures et donc on m'a fait
remarquer que c'était un pléonasme
oui c'est un pléonasme les oiseaux et
temps des dinosaures mais enfin tout le
monde sait de quoi on parle quand on
parle de dinosaures 1
c'est un des problèmes d'ailleurs avec
la classification phylogénétique c'est
la classification phylogénétique n'a pas
que des avantages elle a aussi un énorme
inconvénient c'est que maintenant quand
on dit dinosaures c'est inclus oiseaux
ce qui rend le terme oiseaux ce qui
rendent les termes oiseaux et dinosaures
redondant or la classification c'est
fait pour nous aider théoriquement c'est
quelque chose de purement arbitraire
qu'on impose à la nature pour mieux la
comprendre
or maintenant il ya une énorme confusion
qui a été créée par le fait qu'on veut
que les oiseaux soient inclus dans les
dinosaures
donc en fait on vit on a créé une
classification qui nous aide à
comprendre le vivant est maintenant là
en la rendant phylogénétique en fait ça
crée une nouvelle confusion puisque le
terme dinosaures et oiseaux ne devienne
retour dans exactement comme dans ce
titre
donc je sais bien qu'il suffirait de
dire dinosaures non aviens mais c'est
lourd comme formulation dinosaures non
aviens ça devient encore pire quand vous
êtes obligés de dire tetra peau de mort
dont tétrapodes donc bref on m'a fait
des commentaires sur ce titre bon c'est
pas moi qui les écrit le titre mais bon
c'est clair que moi je ne pense pas que
j'aurais écrit différemment en fait il a
un crâne de dinosaures non aviens donc
oui ce crâne de dinosaures non aviens on
le voit il est là donc voilà ça c'est
non c'est pas lui ça c'est un crâne de
dinosaures pour qu'on par exemple de
dinosaures non aviens pour comparaison
voici le l'oiseau en question son petit
crâne et son petit crâne donc vous voyez
c'est un oiseau avec des dents avec
voyez la forme de la boîte crânienne
très typique des oiseaux et avec deux
fosses temporal voyez fausse temporal
inférieure et la fosse temporal
supérieur qui est presque complètement
fermée mais pas encore totalement donc
ce qui fait de notre petit oiseau un
oiseau à crâne d'arc aux ors et ça c'est
cool c'est cool parce que c'est pas
souvent qu'on que ça a pu être mis en
avant ça a déjà été mis en avant dans
d'autres fossiles c'est pas nouveau et
particulièrement nouveau mais celui là
ça se voit quand même vachement bien
voilà le spécimen ici ce spécimen il est
aussi intéressant alors il a pas d'elle
et il n'a qu'une seule patte mais par
contre on voit bien là que vous voyez là
que est relativement longue
par contre quand vous voyez sur le scan
là là vous avez quelques vertèbres non
soudé et là vous avez le pig hostile
donc la queue est relativement longue
mais possède un pic au style et ça c'est
quand même vachement intéressant je
trouve d'avoir d'avoir cette combinaison
de caractère en fait la queue à qui est
à la fois longues et qui porte un pig
hostile ça le place bien comme come
espèce intermédiaire voilà on aime bien
ça les espaces intermédiaires surtout
quand on a des copains créationnistes
mais la grosse grosse grosse news
scientifique de la semaine que vous avez
dû voir passer que vous avez dû voir
passer et qui a été très très très mal
comprise parce que parce qu'elle est
passée avec une autre news qui lui
ressemble beaucoup c'est la découverte
d'une nouvelle espèce d'hominidé enfin
du genre oh no même d'ailleurs donc une
nouvelle espèce du genre homo en asie et
en fait il y en a eu deux séparés par
deux jours d'intervalle
il y en a eu une découverte en chine
celle que je vais vous présenter
maintenant et y en a eu une découverte
en israël que je vais vous présenter
juste après donc déjà rien que ça ça du
[ __ ] le bordel dans vos têtes mais
alors de façon cosmique
parce que vous avez deux nouvelles
espèces du genre homo découvert en asie
qui sont présentés au public en même
temps veut pas dire qu'ils ont été
découverts en même temps pas du tout
mais ils ont été présentés en même temps
et ça ça ça va aider personne voilà
d'autant que ça a été présenté par la
presse exactement de la même façon à
savoir une nouvelle espèce du genre
moscou l'arbre évolutif de l'homme
change tout ce qu'on croyait savoir
bref alors que c'est pas vrai du tout
encore une fois en face il a pour le
coup celle là c'est pas tellement la
découverte des nouvelles espèces
d'ailleurs qui va changer pas mal de
choses que ce qu'ils en ont fait en les
étudiants c'est plus ça qui va être très
intéressant est ce que je vais vous
montrer maintenant
donc on commence déjà par homo longhi
l'homme dragon voilà longhi qui vient de
l'ongle le dragon chinois donc homologue
guy nouvelle espèce de mini n'est nommé
à partir du crâne d'arbine est le crâne
d'arbine vous vous en souvenez de tête
mais j'en avais parlé sur une ancienne
vidéo dont je vous affiche la vigne est
maintenant et puis un petit lien si vous
les lavoirs en fait le saut crâne
d'arbine que vous voyez là à l'écran sur
la miniature de la vidéo c'est un crâne
en fait tout à l'époque où il l'avait
présentée au public il a été découvert
en 1943 donc il a été découvert il ya
très très longtemps mais il a été
présenté au public il ya seulement
quelques années et à l'époque il avait
essayé de faire passer ça pour l'ancêtre
d'homo sapiens plaçant de fait le
l'origine d'homo sapiens en asie ou
alors soutenant que homo sapiens
asiatique est homo sapiens africain
n'était pas la même espèce c'est ce
qu'on appelle le modèle multi régional
donc c'est le ce crâne
il venait la [ __ ] la merde et moi je
m'étais un peu plein que la chine essayé
peut-être un peu tirer la couverture une
couverture quelqu'un qui a rien à faire
là quoi que la chine essayer de tirer la
couverture de l'origine d'homo sapiens
et il ya beaucoup de chercheurs chinois
il ya beaucoup d'articles qui sont
publiés qui essayent effectivement de
forcer une origine d'homo sapiens en
chine
quitte à dire que homo sapiens de chine
n'est pas le même qu'au mot sapiens
d'afrique et que le fait qu'on soit un
terreau fécond et qu'on ait la même
tronche tout ça c'est une coïncidence et
les mêmes gènes surtout c'est une
coïncidence
donc il ya c'est ce qu'on appelle le
modèle multi régional que je critique
abondamment dans d'autres vidéos pareil
je vous mets le petit lien mais bref
voilà c'est c'est quelque chose dont
j'avais déjà parlé donc ce crâne
d'arbine donkey et le crâne que vous
voyez ici
ce crâne d'arbine donc ils l'ont enfin
des crises aie aie aie aie apparemment
il est suffisamment différent des autres
espèces du genre bon pour qu'on en fasse
une nouvelle espèce homo longhi on va
discuter de ce que ça jusqu'à quel point
on peut se fier à ça pendant la
discussion de ce sur cet article
ce que je trouve très intéressant à
propos de cet article c'est pas
tellement qu'ils décrivent une nouvelle
espèce du genre homo la description
d'une nouvelle espèce du genre homo je
pense qu'elle est justifiée vous voyez
que le crâne par rapport à un homo
sapiens par rapport à néanderthal par
rapport à ici ces homos rhodésienne 6 et
par rapport à un erectus voyez qu'il est
quand même assez différent pas si
différent que ça de néandertal mais vous
voyez que le volume crânien enfin le la
partie frontale du cra
mais quand même plus haute le museau est
plus large
le crâne en général est beaucoup plus
gros et plus robuste que celui de
néandertal et les yeux sur tous les yeux
sont tristes je vous avais déjà dit que
vous avez déjà expliqué dans d'autres
vidéos homo sapiens a les yeux tristes
néandertal a les yeux neutre et d'albert
guen cissé rhodésienne 6 ils ont l'air
en colère
et lui il a plutôt les yeux tristes en
fait il a des orbites rectangulaire et
ça ça fait très homo sapiens du coup il
a les yeux tristes mais avec des groupes
bourrelet sur son orbite r comme un et
d'albert gagnent 6 donc c'est une
combinaison de caractère qu'on ne voit
pas ailleurs
donc je pense que c'est justifié de
vouloir en faire une nouvelle espèce
faut-il appeler homologué par contre ça
va ça va être quelque chose qu'on peut
discuter
le volume crânien est celui d'un être
humain d'un être humain sapiens moderne
1400 centimètres cubes
mais ce qu'il ya d'intéressant donc je
disais avec cet article c'est pas
tellement la description du crâne en
lui-même d'ailleurs l'article en lui
même est paru en trois articles en
réalité il ya un article qui décrit le
crâne et le place dans une nouvelle
espèce l'article que je vous montre
maintenant qui est la phylogénie et
l'article numéro 3 qui est l'article qui
date
le fossile qui donne une date aux
fossiles date qui est de l'ordre de 140
millions si je ne m'abuse c'est écrire à
846 milan voilà donc il ya trois
articles c'est un article en dlc si vous
voulez vous n'avez pas tout le truc d'un
coup il est en plusieurs parties et donc
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant avec cet
article
et bien c'est cette philosophie ils ont
pris le temps de faire une fille le
génie de toutes les espèces en fin de la
plupart des spécimens appartenant au
genre homo du pléistocène
c'est un effort immense j'allais dire
cataclysmique veut cataclysmique parce
que le résultat qu'ils montrent les
résultats qu'ils ont sont à la fois
extrêmement cohérent il y avait je veux
dire il ya vraiment un signal ils sont à
la fois extrêmement cohérent et ils
foutent en l'air à peu près tout ce
qu'on croyait savoir de la
classification y compris des choses que
j'ai pu dire dans d'autres vidéos donc
donc c'est ça ouais c'est un effort
gigantesque
et c'est complètement inattendu parce
que comme je voulais déjà expliqué plein
de fois la plupart des paléontologues
des paléoanthropologues sont pas
spécialement copain avec la phylogénie
et notamment avec les analystes
cladistique est là pour le coup ils ont
utilisé alors ils ont à la fois utiliser
du bayer zia mais ils ont aussi utilisé
de la parcimonie
oui ici voilà donc ils ont aussi utilisé
une analyse cladistique classique
ils ont utilisé les deux il trouva
réseau un résultat très cohérent alors
au niveau des caractères ils ont utilisé
beaucoup beaucoup de caractère continu
par rapport au caractère discret les
caractère discret c'est les caractères
que vous qu des présents absents alors
que les caractères continue c'est les
mesures en fait vous prenez des mesures
vous mettez ça dans votre analyse
statistique
la plupart des gens qui travaillent avec
la parcimonie n'aime pas faire des
mesures parce que la partie simoni
n'aime pas du tout traiter ce genre de
caractère elle donne des résultats qui
sont souvent tout cas qu'avec ça donc
c'est intelligent d'avoir utilisé le
bail est bien avec ce type de caractère
d'autant qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
caractère il ya à peu près 600 caractère
je crois il y en a 400 qui sont des
mesures
donc c'est plus intelligent d'avoir
traité ça avec dubai vient qu'avec de la
clad eastick je pense donc c'est bonne
méthode et le résultat est incroyable je
n'ai jamais été aussi content de lire un
article de ma vie je je tiens à vous le
dire
ça a été un comme un petit orgasme voilà
de voir cette phylogénie qui épatera
c'est avec les doigts apparaître à
l'écran me dire ça y est ils l'ont fait
ils ont fait une phylogénie de homo du
pléistocène
ils ont tout mis dedans ils ont fait
spécimens par spécimens c'est à dire
qu'ils n'ont pas fait genre à sare tous
ces spécimens là on va l'écho des
ensembles en disant que ces homo sapiens
non ils ont pris ce spécimen par
spécimens donc on va je vous assure
qu'on va passer du temps à décortiquer
ça je vais mettre des time code dans la
dans la barre en dessous dans l'est dans
la description pour que vous puissiez de
sauter si ça vous intéresse pas mais je
vous assure que là on va passer du temps
là dessus parce que c'est beau ce qui se
pose c'est beau la ce qui se passe à
l'écran là donc arbres phylogénétiques
voici la racine de l'arbre donc enraciné
enraciné ici
vous avez homo erectus ici vous avez
homo heidelbergensis là vous avez
néandertal ici vous avez la nouvelle
espèce homo longhi alors c'est ce qu'ils
appellent au melon guy ici et vous avez
homo sapiens ici alors on va commencer
par le parce qu'on connaît mieux on va
commencer par homo sapiens voilà donc
voici à chaque fois il ya un petit crâne
associés donc c'est bien ça illustre en
plus donc en moi sapiens on voit que
leur analyse claude eastick retrouve les
grands classiques d'homo sapiens dans en
position homo sapiens on voit notamment
aux modeuses donc les crânes de homo de
d'ethiopie qui sont attribués à homo
homo sapiens et qui sont classiquement
considéré comme appartenant au mot
sapiens sont bien là vous avez les
crânes de skull qui sont les crânes
parmi les premiers homo sapiens qui ont
quitté l'afrique donc ici vous avez les
crânes domo qui viennent d'en dehors de
l'afrique comme par exemple qu'à faisait
qui est en israël
enfin dans moyen-orient comme ce col et
vous avez cro magnon l'homo sapiens
typiquement européen vous avez des
crânes chinois aussi enfin asiatiques
donc ici vous avez homo sapiens ici là à
partir de là vous avez homo sapiens hors
d'afrique et vous avez même d'ailleurs
l'article ils ont utilisé le bayer vient
aussi pour pouvoir dater les événements
alors eux ils mettent quand même une
sortie d'afrique qui est à 415 415 mille
ans 415 mille ans et quand même il ya
longtemps pour une sortie d'afrique
donc ça semble ça semble quand même
lointain peut-être que leurs dettes sont
pas si fiable que ça la méthode
bayésienne à l'utilisent les caractères
si vous voulez vous lui mettez un modèle
évolutif et puis elle va calculer une
longueur de branches donc comme une
horloge moléculaire en fait un calcul et
une date
elle va calculer une longueur de
branches à partir des caractères que
vous mettez dedans sauf qu'avec
seulement 600 caractère vous avez une
marge d'erreur assez phénoménal
normalement c'est fait pour fonctionner
avec des milliers de caractères des
millions même de caractère des millions
de paires de bases puisque c'est fait
pour fonctionner avec de la génétique
normalement donc là ils l'ont utilisée
c'est c
comment dire ça a le mérite d'être là
mais bon je ne mettrai pas de grosses
grosses de grosse grosse confiance dans
ces dates là mais 415 mille ans c'est
quand même beaucoup plus tôt que les
cent mille ans qu'on est sensé qu'on est
censé trouver normalement si on cherche
quand homo sapiens est sorti d'afrique
ceci dit il discute quand même plus tard
dans le texte il discute quand même
qu'il y à des événements de mixage de
2,2 de croisements entre homo sapiens et
néandertal qui ont été datés de cette
fourchette de temps là quatre cent mille
ans donc il n'est pas complètement
impossible
vous avez notamment cet échange de
chromosome y si je me rappelle bien dont
j'avais parlé dans un précédent paléo
news cet échange de chromosome y qui
avait eu lieu il ya quatre cent mille
ans et dont on savait pas trop quoi
faire
bah voilà peut-être que homo sapiens est
sorti d'afrique beaucoup plus tôt qu'on
ne le croyait
mais on va voir que dans cet arbre les
sorties d'afrique c'est quelque chose
qui arrive est très très souvent
apparemment d'après cet arbre donc l'
homo sapiens monde africain et vous avez
ici les crânes typiquement africains
notamment floris bat d'afrique du sud et
le fameux djebel est rude
voilà qui finit par me homo sapiens
malgré tout ce que j'ai pu en dire qui
finit par me homo sapiens donc c'est ce
qu'on pourrait appeler les homo sapiens
de morphologie archaïque alors jebali
route moi ce que je conteste et surtout
c'est qu'ils en faisaient un homo
sapiens moderne dans homo sapiens
moderne c'est à partir de homo donc
qu'est-ce qui différencie les deux
basses et vous voyez le front qui est
beaucoup plus haut que sur djebel est
rude le bourrelet sus orbitaire qui est
beaucoup plus réduit la phase qui est
beaucoup moins large beaucoup plus
étroite le museau moins proéminent et le
menton aussi djebel irun n'a pas de
menton alors que romo homo sapiens
d'anatomie moderne lui a un menton donc
là le clad qui commence à partir d' homo
ici qui englobe tout ça donc aux maux
qui représente l'origine africaine de
homo sapiens archaïque et les homo
sapiens qui ont migré ensuite hors
d'afrique
tout ça c'est homo sapiens
anatomiquement modernes et là à la base
vous avez homo sapiens anatomiquement
archaïque qui est donc par affi
l'éthique comme on s'y attend puisque il
est défini sur l'archaïsme de son de son
anatomie donc cédé caractère typiquement
primitif qui donne généralement ce genre
de résultat à savoir des groupes para
fils éthiques donc là on à homo sapiens
bien bien définis par cette analyse
cladistique on a même une liste
il donne une liste des caractères qui
permettent de définir homo sapiens la
plupart sont des caractères continue
donc ses démesures donc ça va être pas
beaucoup on va dire si vous voulez
utiliser ça pour vous cours quelle est
la définition d'homo sapiens du point de
vue cladistique ça va pas beaucoup vous
aider mais il ya quand même deux trois
caractère continu mais hélas qui sont
très très spécialisés quoi céder
caractère que uniquement des
spécialistes je pense vont vont
comprendre et donc homo sapiens est
lui-même groupe frère d'un clac qui
inclut ce nouveau ce nouveau aux maux
longue ici le crâne d'arbine donc harbin
selon leur analyse cladistique est le
groupe frère d'homo sapiens et cet
article en face cette découverte a
essentiellement été vendus là dessus
vous avez certainement vu passer que cet
homo longhi et elle était plus proche de
l'homo sapiens et l être humain le plus
proche d'homo sapiens qui existe qui
existé par le passé plus proche
d'ailleurs que ne l'est néandertal
si vous regardez néandertal et là c'est
le clad c'est même pas le clad suivants
parce que vous avez d'abord l'homme de
stein et ensuite vous avez seulement
néandertal donc c'est sait même pas ça
c'est vraiment un truc qui serait très
très proche de homo sapiens cette
nouvelle home de chine donc il n'avait
pas si tort que ça en disant
effectivement qu'on a qu'ils avaient
peut-être quelque chose de très proche
de vos sapiens ceci étant dit maintenant
ceci étant dit ça c'est l'analyse
cladistique qu'ils ont fait à partir des
caractères morphologiques mais quid de
l'ue signal donné par les gêne parce
qu'il ya des analyses génétiques qui
aurait pu être fait sur néandertal
l'hédonisme
viens et tout ça qu'est ce que ça
raconte comment sa se compare à ça c'est
là que ça devient intéressant c'est vrai
que ça devient intéressant parce que
harbin là ils se branchent avec homo
antecessor que vous voyez là homo
antecessor qui est donc celui qui a été
découvert en espagne à la fameuse cimade
et le souhait sauce et qui est alors qu
il yad abord été interprété comme un
prêt néandertaliens mais qui maintenant
qu'on a fait des analyses génétiques
dessus alors il ya eu deux grosses
analyses génétiques qui ont été faites
une qui placent en tc sort comme groupe
frère de néandertal et sapiens dont caen
tc sort à l'extérieur de néandertal et
sapiens et une autre qui placent en tc
sort comme groupe frère de denisova et
donc ça ça à 2 résultat ces deux
résultats très intéressants parce que
groupe frère de denisot va regarder quel
est le groupe frère dante et ses soeurs
ici tac bim
c'est notre harbin ce serait notre homme
dragon l'homme chinois qui ça ça donne
envie quand même de s'imaginer un monde
où si ça se trouve notre homologué ce
serait en fait
denisot va depuis le début et ça c'est
super intéressant alors il va falloir
faire des analyses génétiques sur le
crâne d'arbine ou sur du matériel qu'on
arrivera à déterminer comme appartenant
à homologuer mais voilà c'est quand même
une hypothèse super intéressante c'est
juteux comme hypothèse quoi ça ça donne
envie là ça donne envie la septième est
ce qu'on aurait enfin découvert de
quelle tête avaient denisot va donc
éventuellement s'il aurait cette tête
le voilà notre notre homme d'arbine donc
ça se trouve tu vois la grâce à ce crâne
ils ont réussi à reconstituer une tête
ce serait la tête de denisot bas bon ça
ressemble furieusement à un héros bertal
d'accord en plus bruns voilà donc donc
c'est intéressant c'est très très
intéressant comme résultat est alors
l'autre partie qui est intéressante
c'est si denise et si hanter ses soeurs
se branche à l'extérieur là donc cela
c'est ça devient intéressant parce que
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ici c'est pour
ça que j'ai mis des points d'exclamation
en fait quand on oblige l'heure
phylogénie à suivre la topologie des
phylogénie moléculaire c'est à dire
quand on oublie
cet arbre là à suivre les hypothèse
phylogénétique donné par les analyses
génétiques donc quand on associe
finalement les données morphologiques et
les données moléculaires ensemble les
données génétiques ensemble ce qu'ils
disent c'est qu'ils trouvent un arbre ou
le harbin et groupe frère de néandertal
et ça c'est pareil ça semble denisot va
ça harbin gong frère de néandertal bon c
c d'autres analyses généré génétiques
qui ont bien monde qui soutiennent bien
qu'ils soutiennent très fortement que
néandertal et denisot va son groupe
ferait donc quelles que soient les
analyses génétiques à qui on donne la
faveur il existe un monde où ce nouveau
au mont longhi et est un très très très
très très très bon candidat pour être
l'homme de denisova et ça c'est beau
c'est beau [ __ ] c'est beau [ __ ] et
ça vous suggère aussi d'ailleurs que vu
que quand on associe les données
morphologiques aux données moléculaires
il n'est plus le groupe frère du coup
puisqu'il devient il devient le groupe
frère de néandertal donc il n'est plus
le groupe frère domo ça veut aussi dire
que la presse nous a un peu survendu ça
comme groupe frère de de l'homme moderne
fin d'homo sapiens non bref c'est juteux
ses juteux à souhait c'est juste la
souris ensuite on passe à néandertal
regardez néandertal il est là tout ça là
c'est que du néandertal n'y a pas de pré
néandertaliens et ça c'est aussi où
chaque homme résultat les prêts en garde
les prêts néandertaliens ne forment pas
un clad avec néandertal les prélats
néandertaliens on en retrouvait là par
exemple et petra l'ona le fameux crâne
de pétra l'ona dont on a parlé dans un
des bonnes kg pénitence bah justement où
aussi où on parlait aussi du modèle
multi régional et on disait que c'était
kaka et que utiliser le crâne de pétrole
ona pour dire que petra lovas est
l'ancêtre d'homo sapiens et homo sapiens
en europe
hyper kaka parce que là vous avez vos
homo sapiens d'europe ils sont là et
vous avez petra l'ona qui est ici
groupe frère d'ailleurs d'un homo
rhodésienne 6 donc peut être à l'honneur
donc ce serait un crâne grecque qui dont
le plus proche parent serait un crâne
retrouvé au zimbabwe ou en zambie
non c'est en zambie je crois broken hill
donc mais bref très intéressant qu'on
retrouve en afrique de manière générale
donc c'est très très très très
intéressant très intéressant donc on à
néanderthal ici dépourvu de ses
camarades près néandertaliens donc il ya
que du néandertal qui forment un groupe
monofil éthique donc ça veut dire ça
choquera personne on est bien d'accord
et là vous avez un petit paquet d'autres
crâne qui sont classiquement attribué à
homo sapiens archaïques ou non ou pré
néandertaliens ou rhodésienne si c'est
pareil ici ou engelberg n 6 sur tout et
là vous avez donc les aides dahlberg n 6
et rhodésienne 6 ici donc si vous suivez
la chaîne ça fait longtemps que je vous
parle de la dahlberg m6 en vous disant
que c'est le bordel avec et d'albert
guentis parce que il ya des aides à la
base et de bergues n 6 a été défini en
europe et est censé être et est censé
être un prêt néandertaliens puis on l'a
découvert en afrique puis on l'a
découvert en chine puis les gens ont
décidé que non en fait c'était
rhodésienne 6 en afrique avec le en
chine c'était encore autre chose
les chinois ont décidé qu'en chine
s'était directement des descendants
d'homo erectus par exemple et que ses
descendants d'homo erectus étaient pour
certains étaient les ancêtres de l'homo
sapiens donc la fameuse théorie
multirégional bref homo heidelbergensis
ça a toujours été un joyeux bordel
parce que parce que ça ressemble
furieusement à de l'homo sapiens
archaïque et ça ressemble aussi à de
l'homo erectus tardif ou à dupré
néandertaliens et homo heidelbergensis
et ben maintenant avec cette phylogénie
on donne on met de l'ordre à tout ça
donc
hedberg n 6 et la mandibule de mawer ici
mawer hélas sa tâche avec d'autres
spécimen qui viennent apparemment
d'espagne donc ça c'est du heysel berg n
6 et vous voyez que heidelbergensis est
bon il est pas du tout prêt
néandertaliens si c'était un prénom et
roberta bien et de bergues m6 il devrait
être là sauf que là il est là donc ça
veut dire que là on a des événements de
dispersion hors d'afrique direction
l'europe à répétition pourquoi je dis
hors d'afrique bas parce que là vous
avez erectus afrique africains donc la
racine et habilis africains donc la
racine de l'arbre est africaine et vous
avez des événements de dispersion en
asie donc les fameux le fameux homo
erectus qui s'est dispersé en asie il ya
1,8 million d'années donnant naissance
vous avez l'homme de manille sida par
exemple donc magnifique qui se
dispersent en asie même là c'est
compliqué d'ailleurs parce que vous avez
de l'africa et de voilà ça c'est de
l'africain ça c'est de l'afrique un sas
et de l'asiatique saas et de l'afrique
un sas et d'asiatiques et ça c'est de
l'asiatique donc vous avez un mélange
d'africains et d'asiatiques est bref et
voilà vous avez donc de nouveaux
événements de dispersion et vous voyez
que dans chacun il ya un crâne africain
là c'est un crâne africain bout d'os et
africains broken heels est africain
mélanger saldana il me semble que ces
africains aussi mélangé avec des crânes
européen de tergnier fine et ça s'est
ternie fini il me semble que c'est un
add
petra l'onas et en grèce ceprano ça doit
être en espagne arago ça doit être en
espagne là vous avez des crânes
essentiellement asiatiques donc indiens
et chinois
et là vous avez encore un crâne
d'origine africaine on s'est toujours
plus ou moins le bordel mais maintenant
c'est leur donner c'est à dire que
hedberg m6 c'est juste ces deux là
maintenant broken heels et rhodésienne 6
donc rhodésienne si ça pourrait
correspondre à ceux clad si du coup donc
vous auriez baudot ceprano petra l'ona
voilà qui correspondrait à d'autres
événements de migration hors d'afrique
enfin bref vous auriez vous auriez une
racine essentiellement africaine avec
des événements de dispersion en
direction de l'asie
très
très souvent en fait extrêmement souvent
à tel point que en viennent à faire
l'hypothèse que peut-être qu'en fait il
y avait un ping pong entre l'asie et
l'afrique avec des fois la racine
peut-être de l'arbre qui a pu bouger dès
fois de entre l'asie et l'afrique
c'est à dire qu'entre l'afrique de l'est
et le moyen-orient parce que évidemment
le moyen-orient fait techniquement
partie de l'asie je veux dire entre
l'afrique de l'est et le moyen-orient
c'est facile de jouer au ping pong et la
racine du coup à chaque fois la cc ne
l'a que vous voyez là ils ont pu le
jouer au ping pong à chaque fois entre
l'afrique et l'asie
donc ça c'est un résultat absolument
prodigieux et ça et ça vous ordonne
complètement le truc quoi ça ça y est
c'est plus le bordel maintenant et
d'albert guentis maintenant ces malwares
et ses crânes la rhodésie m6 maintenant
c'est le seul ce gala broken hill le
crâne de kaboul est le lot type on
pourrait dire et les trucs qui se
branche à lui voilà bon et puis il passa
c'est une nouvelle espèce du genre oh
boy qu'il faudra donner un nom un jour
et ça c'est une nouvelle branche tout
seul lui aussi c'est une nouvelle espèce
du genre homo eux c'est pareil c'est
probablement une nouvelle espèce du
genre homo et qu'il faudra donner un nom
un jour voilà voilà la puissance de la
phylogénie ce que ça vous dit et
d'ailleurs on peut parler maintenant
parlons sérieusement de l'origine
asiatique du genre homo qui a été donc
amené sur la table en partie par le
crâne d'arbine origine asiatique du
genre de nos qui n'est du coup pas
soutenu par cette analyse phylogénétique
voilà ici donc c'est le même arbre mais
retourné 1
donc n'ayez pas peur c'est pas une
nouvelle analyse c'est le même arbre à
l'envers et ici vous avez voyage des
petits quartiers qui vous indique si
c'est la probabilité que l'option
africains asiatiques européennes ou
africaines donc là vous avez homo
sapiens comme tout à l'heure homo
sapiens probabilité d'être africain
quasiment 100%
et là vous voyez probabilité d'être
africain ici est très forte donc ça
c'est l'ancêtre en commun de harbin donc
de homologué
et dans tcsa et de homo sapiens ici à là
par contre vous voyez c'est le ping pong
là vous avez l'ancêtre en commun de
néandertal et de et de homo sapiens est
de harbin donc là vous avez une plus
haute probabilité d'une origine
européenne c'est normal puisqu'on a
hanté ses sorts qui va se mettre quelque
part par là et on a un autre crâne ici
qui a l'air d'être européen et là on à
néandertal qui est purement européen
donc là on a effectivement une eau plus
haute probabilité d'être d'une origine
européenne
je rappelle que néandertal dont on sait
qu'il apparaît en europe mais on sait
toujours pas d'où il vient et jusqu'à
présent penser qu'ils venaient d'afrique
donc là on aurait peut-être une origine
européenne donc peut-être à ce carrefour
justement entre l'afrique l'asie et
l'europe que se trouve être le
moyen-orient donc ça avait quand même
une probabilité non négligeable qui est
une origine africaine toujours hélas
après c'est l'afrique qui domine
largement
sauf là où il ya une probabilité
asiatiques n'ont nulle puisque vous avez
des homo erectus asiatiques qui sont
tous branchés l'a donc là la limite je
vais plus à un billet au niveau de la
deûle et le championnat il faut voir
aussi que l'échantillonnage il est
largement dominé par des spécimens
asiatique un bien évidemment ceux des
chercheurs chinois qui ont fait l'étude
il avait accès à plus de matériel
asiatique évidemment mais il faut voir
que la l'échantillonnage est très très
biaisée en faveur du matériel asiatiques
mais les africains sont voyez il ya des
îles sont ils sont un peu partout quand
même voilà et quand on prend la
phylogénie en compte et ben on se rend
compte que les os les spécimens
africains sont comme ça comme du poivre
voyez ils sont saupoudrés un peu partout
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya toujours une
attache africaine voilà ça maintient
toujours il attache africaine et ça
maintient l'incertitude au niveau de ces
probabilités sur les origines en dehors
d'afrique
c'est à dire que même quand vous avez
une origine presque quasi certaine en
dehors d'afrique vous avez toujours ces
petits gars là pour brancher par ci par
là qui vous rappelle que et vient par là
c'est en afrique que ça se passe
peut-être et ouais donc
r on voit aussi que bah du coup il ya
malgré tout ce qu'on peut vous dire sur
la recherche des origines humaines en
afrique il n'ya pas beaucoup de
spécimens qui viennent d'afrique ce qui
suggère qu'il ya pas eu beaucoup de
recherches qui ont été faites en afrique
donc il ya quand même du travail à
accomplir pour trouver plus de matériel
je pense en afrique qui permettrait de
soutenir ou pas l'origine africaine de
homo sapiens en tout cas homo sapiens là
vous voyez il est solidement enracinée
en afrique à la limite vous avez cela
qui est l'ancêtre en commun d'homo
sapiens d'arbine en fin de 2e homologué
est d' homo neandertalensis qui pourrait
éventuellement être d'origine européenne
voilà et là vous avez une probabilité un
peu supérieure à 50% ici et là de d'une
origine asiatique de cet ancêtre en
commun si voilà donc ces voix là c'est
une analyse qui est absolument enfin qui
était nécessaire et qui illumine
beaucoup sur notre notre origine quoi
c'est fou ça et ça fait le ménage comme
je le disais dans les dalles bergen 6
toutes les fois où j'ai dit à dole berg
n 6 c'est la même chose que homo sapiens
archaïque là toutes les fois où dans mes
précédentes vidéos là vous pouvez aller
les comptes et si vous voulez je les dis
plein de fois toutes les fois où j'ai
dit à dahlberg n 6 s'est comme homo
sapiens archaïque c'est comme monter ses
sorts c'est tout ça c'est la même chose
ben non ça y est cette analyse
elle démontre enfin que non ce n'était
pas le cas ce n'était pas le cas
voilà ce n'était pas calé l'edl bergen
six voiliers ils sont là et c'est ces
deux là et ils sont très très loin de ce
qu'on appelle homo sapiens archaïque qui
est ici phylogénétiquement du moins ils
sont très éloignées dans le temps ils
ont vécu en même temps tout ça en plus
faut vous imaginer c'est du monde qui a
vécu en même temps vous imaginez combien
il y avait des espèces qui vivait en
même temps du genre homo et qui sont pas
si éloignées nous et je veux dire au
niveau morphologiques voyez c'est pas
des c'est pas des singes
ça c'était des choses qu'on aurait enfin
des espèces qu'on aurait identifié comme
des êtres humains tout ça donc c'est
assez ouf c'est assez ouf comme résultat
voilà je suis désolé dit avoir passé
tant de temps mais
ça ça va partir dans mes cours mes
direct ça si vous êtes ainsi vous êtes
prof et que vous enseignez l'évolution
humaine et que vous êtes capable de
comprendre une statistique
je veux dire c'est que vous êtes capable
de lire une analyse cladistique mettez
ça dans vos cours mettez ça dans vos
courses et c'est en or massif c'est
merveilleux mais ce qui vient de se
produire ça à tout démolir je veux dire
je suis le premier à dire ça a démoli
complètement tout ce que je croyais
savoir sur un modèle bergen six mois je
pensais qu'elle doit le bergen sicile le
trouverait là et ben non ils ne trouvent
pas là et il trouve que rhodésienne si
ce n'est pas la même chose que de la
berline 6 et il trouve quand tu essaies
sort n'est pas la même chose qu'un
prenne meilleur d'herta lien il trouve
qu'il ya les prêts néandertaliens c'est
même pas un truc qui existe je veux dire
les nerfs des prêts néandertaliens ça
n'existe même plus voilà c'est fini
c'est non c'est ça fait partie d'une
autre vague de migration hors d'afrique
qui a atteint l'europe néandertal il est
arrivé après ils ont rien à voir les que
ces produits s'est produit je vois là
j'ai rien d'autre à dire c'est
merveilleux à côté de ça le prochain
article du cou qui est lui aussi paru
alors qu'il lui est paru dans nature's
way cet article sur romo longue il est
paru dans the innovation donc c'est même
pas un article dans les chairs mais
celui là par contre il de sortie dans la
nature ou signs je sais plus je vous
avoue que je confonds les deux sayan
voilà il est sorti dans ses alliances et
cet article il fait un petit peu pâle
figure à côté parce que lui nous annonce
la découverte d'une nouvelle espèce du
genre homo en israël du coudon au
moyen-orient nouvelles espèces qui les
représentent et donc par un bout de
crâne et un bout de mandibules voilà que
vous voyez là le bout de crâne
ici le bout de mandibules là alors selon
eux ils ont fait des analyses qui sont
alors il n'y a pas d' analyse
phylogénétique voilà on retombe dans le
travers classique le travers classique d
d d d études paléoanthropologie que le
truc qui ressemble plus à un arbre
phylogénétique c'est ça et puis ça en
dessous celui là donc on a donc c'est de
ces fragments et il décide
il pense en fait que c'est une nouvelle
espèce du genre homo il ne lui ont pas
donné de nom contrairement aux
chercheurs chinois qu'on vient de voir
pour homologuer
ils lui ont pas donné de nom par contre
selon eux en fait c'est c'est un truc
qui serait intermédiaire entre homo
erectus et néandertal t il on fait une
analyse en composante principale alors
c'est compliqué mais en gros quand vous
mesurez plein de trucs et que vous avez
envie d'en tirer un signal
c'est compliqué de comparer tous les
trucs 1 1 donc ce que vous faites c'est
que vous mixez tout ça dans une seule et
même analyse donc c'est ce qu'on appelle
une analyse multivariée vous prenez
plein de variables et voulait voilà vous
faites une grosse compote de variables
et ça vous donne ce résultat là qui est
un résultat en deux axes voilà c'est un
beau tableau avec deux axes donc c'est
facile à lire donc vous avez une compote
de données et cette compote de données
vous donne ce résultat là qui est
beaucoup plus facile à lire et donc la
leur ce qu'ils trouvent c'est qu'en fait
le crâne la forme du crâne est plus
proche de ce carré l'a fait par des
trucs orange c'est à dire homo erectus
et à côté de ça il trouve que la mort
dit bull ici donc 1er 2è les plus
proches alors elle est entre ce triangle
là qui est le triangle bleu foncé c'est
atapuerca donc ça doit être les hanter
ses sorts et ici le truc en vert
c'est-à-dire néandertal donc la
mandibule elle fait effectivement penser
un peu à du néandertal en gros et le
crâne fait un peu penser à de l'homo
erectus alors je pars du principe
effectivement que a priori ça appartient
à la même veste yole ça appartient aux
mêmes spécimens on va leur faire
confiance là dessus mais voilà dans
apparemment est vraiment franchement à
tendance néandertalienne donc bref mais
le truc c'est la date
apparemment il ya aussi un problème au
niveau de la date c'est que c est hyper
jeunes comme crâne entre 140 milles et
120 mille ans donc normalement le si
vous trouvez à si vous trouvez un homo
erectus a tendance néandertalienne et
que vous voulez être sûr que c'est un
homo erectus a tendance néandertalienne
vous auriez plutôt tendance à espérer un
âge entre 400 milles et 600 mille ans
voire même plus vieux que six cent mille
ans vous pouvez même
monter jusqu'à 2 millions d'années quoi
mais vous un stand est à un âge très
vieux 140000 à 120 mille ans c'est très
jeune néandertal est déjà bien
différencier donc d'un point de vue
philosophique éthique ça pose pas de
problème mais du coup ça veut dire qu'on
est face à quelque chose qui à son
époque était une sorte de fossiles
vivants en fait on efface un survivant
en fait de survivants d'une population
qui était autrefois néant ancestrale à
néandertal en fait et qui auraient
survécu au moyen-orient jusqu'à il y à
120 140 millions bon bah comme je le dis
ça manque d' analyse phylogénétique là
j'avoue que je serais très très très
très très curieux de voir si l'analyse
si le placer ce fossile là sur cette
analyse phylogénétique ci confirme
qu'effectivement il vient bien se situer
quelque part par là en fait parce que
c'est ça en fait leur hypothèse c'est
que ça se situe entre néandertal et
erectus donc l'analyse normalement dans
l'analyse phylogénétique il va se
retrouver quelque part par là dans le
joyeux bordel entre les rhodésienne 6 et
les lésés dahlberg n 6 voilà ce qui est
est ce qui de ce qui de fait d'ailleurs
le rendrait beaucoup moins original vue
qui serait loin d'être tout seul dans
cette position ce qui serait très
étonnant par contre ce serait le devoir
se brancher ici sachant qu'il ressemble
beaucoup au wave etc tu ce serait assez
étonnant de le voir se brancher ici mais
c'est pas impossible
la grosse le gros résultat que
j'attendrais ce serait qu'il se branche
par là je pense mais ça on verra ça
quand il y aura d analyse phylogénétique
disponibles ce qui n'a pas été fait dans
cet article là donc on passe au suivant
et l'article suivant est un article qui
a été réalisé par moi même et de
collègues qui décrit pour la première
fois une dent enfoncé dans le museau
d'un gorgone obtient donc voyez là vous
avez le museau du gorgol obtient vous
avez là dedans qui se situe ici la dent
être plantés dans le museau et elle
n'est pas seulement planté dans le
museau elle est entourée d'un petit qu'à
l'us de tissus cicatriciels
qui veut dire que notre gorgone obtient
n'est n'est pas ne s'est pas fait manger
après être mort non il a survécu à cette
morsure la dent est resté planté il a
vécu plusieurs à au moins plusieurs
semaines
avec cette d'en planter de telle sorte
qu'il a développé du tissu cicatriciel
autour de la dent et là on voit bien le
bourrelet que sa forme autour de la dent
donc c'est vraiment là dedans qui a
provoqué la formation que ceux-ci tissu
cicatriciel est absolument aucun doute
là dessus
alors ce qu'il ya d'intéressant avec sa
basse et que les gorgones obtient ils
sont connus pour avoir des grandes dents
de sabre et on aime bien se demander
mais à quoi elle servait ses dents de
sabre chez ces animaux là d'ailleurs je
je je fait justement remarquer que cette
cette reconstitution a été faite par
sophie donc miss plumes voilà donc on
remercie très fort miss plume d'avoir
fait ce ce joli des simple coucou voilà
donc les gorgones obtient ils sont
connus pour leurs dents de sabre et on
se demande fortement à quoi elles
servent et ses dents de sabre est donc
l'une des hypothèses qu'on avance c'est
que cette dent si elle avait si elle
avait été faite par un prédateur en
train d'essayer de bouffe aidante borgo
n'obtient avons déjà les corps de chien
sont des prédateurs eux-mêmes donc c'est
pas évident faudrait trouver un
prédateur plus gros que lui mais avec
des dents tout petit parce que voyez
qu'elle est pas bien grosse 1,7 dans l
arène de mm donc c'est pas une grosse
dent donc ça n'a pas été fait par un
prédateur plus gros que le gorgol
obtient donc faut s'imaginer un gang on
obtient en train d'avoir de se faire
chasser par un autre prédateur qui n'est
pas beaucoup plus gros que lui
ça semble assez peu probable quoique pas
impossible ça pourrait même être du
cannibalisme
mais là où justement ce qui a attiré
notre attention c'est justement que la
dent est plantée dans le museau avec un
call us au tour ce qui veut dire qu'il a
survécu
or quel genre de comportement provoque
des morsures mais ne sont pas destinés à
tuer l'adversaire
ben c'est pas les comportement de
prédation de prédation généralement
c'est fait pour tuer l'adversaire ça
pourrait être effectivement une
prédation raté mais ça pourrait aussi
être un comportement de combat rituel
comme le font beaucoup d'animaux
aujourd'hui beaucoup
comme les babouins qui ont des immenses
canine comme le font les lions comme le
font les ti bref tous les animaux qui
ont des grandes canines aujourd'hui se
battent et se mordent le museau et
occasionnellement des dents reste planté
surtout quand on est sur des animaux qui
ont des remplacements dentaire en série
comme chez les grands bonhommes tient
bon bah là on s'attend bien à trouver ce
genre de comportement qui s'appelle du
faith biting et qui est un comportement
social et qu'on retrouve chez beaucoup
d'animaux aujourd'hui donc peut-être
qu'on ne serait pas fins à une prédation
échoué mais peut-être face à un
comportement social qui irait de pair
justement avec les grandes canines qui
seraient utilisés justement pendant ces
combats sociaux pas seulement quand mme
armes parce que les combats sociaux
justement le but n'est pas de tuer
l'adversaire dans un combat social
notamment si vous vous battez pour
accéder à des femelles par exemple si on
a deux mâles en train de se battre pour
accéder à des femelles ou pour augmenter
la taille de leur territoire ces
comportements sociaux généralement leur
but c'est juste de faire peur à
l'adversaire on veut pas se battre à
mort
donc on se mord oui mais avec les
incisives et les canines elles elles
savent pas tuer elles servent juste à
impressionner l'adversaire d'en face
voilà j'ai des plus grosses j'en ai des
plus grosses que toi à c'est moi qui ai
gagné 250 millions d'années d'évolution
pour en arriver là mais voilà donc et en
plus c'est intéressant parce que ça
vient d'un cargo pia du permien moyens
légaux nokia sont extrêmement rares au
père monnard moyens donc c'est d'autant
plus rare de tous c'est déjà rare de
trouver un gang nokia mais en plus un
cargo nokia avec une d'en planter dans
le museau c'est encore plus rare et le
fait est que ça n'a jamais été trouvée
avant c'est pour ça qu'on apporte comme
la première la première trace de morsure
ya jamais aucune trace de morsure qui a
jamais été trouvées sur aucun gorgo
nokia avançait d'ailleurs sur presque
aucun tayrac side les traces de morsures
n'ont jamais été documentés ça veut dire
qu'elle existe pas ça veut pas dire
qu'elle n'existe pas ça veut dire qu'on
les a jamais vus ce spécimen là par
exemple il a été découvert dans l'est
donc le museau que j'ai étudié la ce
spécimen là il a été découvert dans les
années 40 il a été étudié quatre fois au
moins disons qu'il ya quatre fois où il
a été étudié où ça
portez à publication donc il a peut-être
été étudiée plus souvent que ça mais ça
fait 4 heures il ya quatre personnes qui
lui sont passés dessus sur ce museau et
qui n'ont pas vu cette d'en planter dans
le museau avec un petit qu'à l'us au
tour donc ça vous laisse envisager
combien de trucs on a pu rater combien
de d'éléments de cette de cette nature
on a pu rater chez tous les autres
spécimens de tous les autres thérapies
side qu'on a découvert c'est à dire des
milliers voilà ça fait rêver ça fait
rêver carrément et on espère bien qu'on
va en trouver d'autres des preuves comme
ça parce que ça peut conduire à de
grosses découvertes donc notamment les
comportements sociaux par exemple mais
aussi bas c'est grâce à des dents planté
dans un call us de cicatrisation qu'on a
réussi à prouver que le t-rex
en fait il n'était pas charognards t-rex
est un prédateur
comment on a fait ça on a retrouvé une
vertèbre avec une dent de t-rex dedans
et un tissu cicatriciel autour et ça ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que l'animal
était vivant quand il s'est fait mordre
par le t-rex et donc ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que tyreke ce n'était pas
un charognard fatalement puisque
l'animal était vivant quand il l'a
attaqué voilà donc c'est donc ce genre
de fossiles est super important niveau
paléo biologique
arrivé à perforer de l'os 6 et une
capacité qui tient la puissance des
mâchoires
pareil quand on dit que le t-rex était
capable de broyer les os ça vient pas de
nulle part
ça vient du fait qu'on a retrouvé des
eaux qui ont été broyés associer la
descente de t-rex donc la morsure qui
broie les eaux de t-rex ça vient du fait
qu on l a réussi à qu'on a retrouvé des
fossiles qu'ils montrent qu'ils
démontrent directement que t-rex pouvait
broyer les os c'est pas seulement des
calculs et des mecs qui font joujou avec
des presses hydrauliques comme on voit
dans les documentaires comme par exemple
celui que celui qui est en train de
critiquer valeo raptor là où on voit des
gens en train de vous faire joujou avec
des presses hydrauliques
c'est pas ça qui démontre que t-rex
avait une puissance de mâchoires
gigantesque c'est de trouver un os super
fat de tricératops péter en deux
avec des dandys ax planté dedans ça ça
ça démontre que thirith pouvait péter de
l'os avec ses danses et à partir de là
on peut reconstituer plus ou moins la
solidité d'un os de tricératops et donc
en déduire la puissance des mâchoires de
t-rex voilà la modélisation tout seul
elle sert à rien s'il faut qu'elle soit
basée sur un phénomène concret voilà
donc faire de la 3d et puis des puits
faire joujou avec des presses
hydrauliques ça ne sert à rien par
contre reconstruire après un modèle qui
a la même solidité qu'un os à la même
solidité présumer qu'un os de
tricératops et le mettre sous une presse
hydraulique et augmenter la puissance
jusqu'à ce que l'eau ska exactement de
la façon dont il était donc il a été
cassé par t-rex ça ça vous donne des
indices biologiques
voilà ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
faire joujou avec des pré sident
reliques ça veut juste dire que avant de
jouer avec la presse hydraulique il faut
savoir ce qu'on en fait voilà la
question scientifique est donc là là on
vient d'ouvrir je pense avec cet article
l'article en lui même il démontre pas
grand chose mais cet article démontre
surtout que l'on vient d'ouvrir une
nouvelle boîte quand on vient enfin
d'ouvrir une nouvelle boîte qui est oui
on a laissé passer des choses comme ça
pendant toutes ces années d'épreuves
paléo biologique combien de preuves
paléo biologique ne sont passés sous le
nez sans qu'on les voit donc voilà c'est
ça la grosse contribution de cet article
donc on est très content de l'avoir
publié et il est open access dans
frontiers in ecology and evolution donc
vous pouvez le télécharger librement
voilà on reste dans nos amis du permien
enfin du ici du père mère voilà c'est
dans le titre en main on reste dans les
amis du permien mais on retourne en
france
j'avais envie de montrer cette étude
voilà ça se passe c'est des fossiles
qu'ils ont été découverts dans le sud de
la france voilà dans la région de toulon
si je ne m'abuse
voilà le site est ici dans le bassin du
luc deleu luc et dans le bassin de lui
vous voyez ces belles terres rouges la
très typique du permien européen vous
avez des magnifiques s'emprunte voilà
regardez moi la beauté de la
préservation de ces empreintes c'est
magique
quoi puis regardez la voyez cette petite
sinuosités c'est là que c'est là que
c'est pour ça que les dinosaures ils
traînaient pas là que c'est parce qu'on
retrouve jamais de traces de coups avec
les dinosaures ou alors très très peu
très très peu et généralement elles ont
en plus les accidents tels que la
systématique comme vous pouvez voir la
cda petite empreinte d'un reptile qui
s'appelle un cap torino morph qu'ils
étaient des reptiles du carbonifère est
super bien je crois qu'il y en a une
image un peu plus loin voilà c'est un
cap torino morph c'est sait même pas
considérés comme des paras reptiles ce
sont des reptiles qu'on appelait
autrefois des ânes apside mais qui sont
ni départ un reptile ni des amphibiens
idc à part c'est un petit groupe à paris
voilà ils sont quand même plus proche
des reptiles que des des synapses id on
est d'accord et donc ses caps torino mof
basse et emprunte elle nous indique
comment marcher ses capteurs innovants
ils ont fait plein de plein de belles
hypothèses sur la façon dont se déplacer
les caps torino mof en utilisant des
simulations etc
je vous invite à aller lire cet article
très intéressant
écrit par notre collègue en partie du
moins
écrit en partie par notre collègue jean
sébastien steyer qu'on a invité plein de
fois sur cette chaîne
salut voila mais il ya aussi d'autres
d'autres paléontologues faux 5e français
connus comme andré noël voilà garrouste
tout ça c'est des noms connus de la
paléontologie française et on termine
c'est presque devenu une tradition
maintenant on termine par des
invertébrés
bah oui il faut faire plaisir à nos amis
averti briest donc les invertébrés
aujourd'hui on va parler on va parler
ammonites une fois de plus un article
paru dans scientifiques ou les pentes ce
qui est aussi une succursale du grand
journal du prestigieux noms jordan
venture et qui nous décrit pour la
première fois apparemment les crochets
des tentacules dame dynamo dit
donc les crochets ou tomber en mettre
une image directement chez les
céphalopodes voyez c'est ce qu'il ya au
bout des tentacules alors faut voir que
chez les céphalopodes
vous avez deux types de tentacules vous
avez les tentacules et vous avez les
bras et donc le fait de retrouver
décroché ses ammonites voilà ça montre
qu'elle avait à la fois des tentacules
une paire de tentacules avec des gros
crochet dessus et aussi qu'elle avait
des bras et qu'elle avait huit bras donc
ça me ce qui fait des ammonites des des
capotes
voilà donc si vous vous posiez la
question est ce que les ammonites sont
plus proches des calamars c'est à dire
des décapodes que des pieuvres c'est à
dire dès octobre aux bombes à cet
article vous dit les ammonites avait
décroché vous avez des grandes
tentacules avec des crochets donc ça
doit être d'aider qu'apple voilà si
jamais vous vous posez la question
bon après vous avez quand même les bébés
les minutes qui ont des gros crochet
aussi mais alors apparemment les baies
les minutes ont évolué et enfin on vu
leurs crochets apparaître de façon
convergente c'est à dire c'est pas les
mêmes crochet en plus chez les ammonites
que chez les b limites
alors bon je suis pas spécialiste
d'invertébrés donc je n'ai pas trop
m'aventurer là dedans mais en tout cas
c'est un très très beau fossiles qui a
été étudiée vous voyez par l'imagerie 3d
donc ils ont scanné pour essayer de
sortir le maximum de ses crochets c'est
aussi open access donc vous pouvez aller
le lire librement sans aucun problème
voilà c'était paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et je vous dis à très bientôt